[Music]
tap the banner to learn more
Kia Frisco is always ready to serve your
Automotive needs we have new 2023
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
good evening
welcome to the table
glad to see each one of you here
so glad to see all of our kids as well
you guys are coming in and you got you
grabbed your seats sometimes we have to
get get our adults to do that sometimes
but you guys are doing great it's
amazing
uh welcome to the table when I use Don
Jacobs I'm glad to see each one of you
guys here
um so start off with announcements but
really there's only one major
announcement we're going to go over
today
um so there is a new small group that's
starting off and without me I'm not
going to go into all the details about
that
um so I'm going to invite our leader
who's going to go over some of the
details but it's going to start off with
this this uh Tuesday so well let's talk
about it okay awesome hi everybody I'm
Johnny Horton and I have started coming
here about a year ago and I've decided
that I wanted to share my spiritual
gifts with the congregation
and so I'm offering three classes on
prayer we're just going to explore a
little bit about prayer what might be
difficult for you what might be easy for
you have you ever tried different ways
of praying and so it's open it's going
to be at my home it's going to start at
what time did I say 6 30 7. what time
did I say you're welcome to come it's 6
30 if you want
but we're going to go for about an hour
and a half it'll be really fun relaxing
so you're welcome to sign up if you'd
like
[Applause]
thank you that sounds that sounds very
intriguing uh we're going to get started
with uh worship and we'll start that off
with a quick prayer
Lord thank you so much for bringing us
all to here today thank you for just
this space
this time where we can just come here
and just connect with you
I pray you open up our hearts and our
minds to the words that are going to be
shared during the message and during
worship in Christ I pray amen
right thank you Don
good evening everyone
um so yeah first I want to kind of get
the elephant out of the room yes I'm
going out my hair sorry it's like kind
of crazy
I'm just gonna go with I'm just going
for it you know
anyway so yes would you guys please
stand with us
um
and we'll get started Joe's going to
lead us in our first song
I love you Lord
for you have delivered me
for you have delivered my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living my soul from
my feet from stumbling I will walk in
the land of the living
sing that again
I love you Lord for you have delivered
me
I love you Lord
you have delivered my soul from my feet
from stumbling I will walk in the land
of the living my soul from that my feet
from stumbling I will walk
land of the living
I Will Bless You Lord For You Heard My
Cry I reached out my hand and you saved
my life
[Music]
for your grace
and I love you Lord
you have delivered me
[Music]
I love you Lord
you have delivered my soul friend my
feet from stumbling I will in the land
of the living my soul from my feet from
stumbling I will walk in the land of the
living
foreign
kids
dismissed preschoolers and Kinders to
your right and first through fifth
graders to the left
and yeah
thanks for joining us guys and Joe is
going to go and lead us into the prayers
of the people
all right read along with me
for the city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all of
those who live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it we pray to you for those who
travel on land sea or air we pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and for all who remember
and care for them we pray to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names in
situations up to you
[Music]
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts we pray that they could pray to
you that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence amen
right this next song you may or may not
know it we've done here a couple times
it's not a typical worship song but the
words are really powerful
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
over 85 you fell for your whole life
that when God made you he just messed up
if you've been read the southern belle
born in bread fish show and tell but she
lied down feeling never good enough
I'm so sorry
for how it's been
we're broken artists
with broken pins we paint our pride
and call it truth
sorry no one explained Jesus to you
foreign
[Music]
what you've heard we're broken poets
a silly words we painted genders
and call it truth
sorry no one explained Jesus to you
oh
can't you feeling in the room
all he wants is you thank you
I'm so sorry
for all the wrong
with broken singers
and broken songs we paint our pride
and call it truth
sorry no one explained Jesus to you
sorry no one explained Jesus
[Music]
Amazing
Grace
How Sweet
the Sound
that
saves a rich
like me
[Music]
was gone
but now I'm found
was
mine but
now
I see
[Music]
with me I want to know you Lord
I Wanna Know You Lord
and like I know a friend
like I know a friend I Wanna Know You
Lord
[Music]
All My Religion
I'm laying down
I Wanna Know You Lord
all my religion
I'm laying down I Wanna Know You
Lord
I Wanna Know You Lord
please
and I used to think
that I could box you in
and I'm laying down I Wanna Know You
Lord I used to think
that I could box you in
but I'm laying down
I Wanna Know You Lord
[Music]
Wanna Know You
Lord
so I'm laying down
cause I'm laying down
All My Religion
I'm laying down I Wanna Know You Lord
I'm laying down
how my religion
I'm laying down I Wanna Know You Lord
I Wanna Know You Lord
I've Been Told
to be ashamed
Lord I've Been Told
don't measure
I'm not good enough
but you're here with me
oh I'm reaching out
I reach out in you
find me in the
dust
you said no amount of untruths
[Music]
separator us
I'm reaching now
I reach out in you
fine finding in the dust
you said no amount of untruths
[Music]
separate
us I Will Rejoice I will rejoice in a
simple gospel
I will rejoice
in you Lord I will rejoice
innocent gospel
I will rejoice in you Lord
I will rejoice
in the simple gospel
I will rejoice in you Lord
[Music]
rejoice in the simple gospel
I will rejoice
you long
[Music]
I reach out
I reach out in you
you find me
in the dust
you said no amount of untruths
contemporary
[Music]
good morning
I reach out in you
find me in the dust
you said no amount of
untruths can separate
and I will rejoice
in a simple gospel
I will rejoice
in you Lord
in a simple gospel
I will rejoice
in you Lord
we are so grateful
full of love
and Lord
let us pray tonight that it was as we
listen to the words of the message that
it would fill us Lord
that we would see something different
that we would see transformation Lord
that we would have the courage to hear
your still small voice
and God help us to extend Grace this
world
to be the light that you call us to be
Lord we love you
it's in Jesus name and we pray
amen
hey you want to go ahead and turn to
someone next to you and say hi there
foreign
welcome welcome it's so so good to be
with you all
um my name is Brett I'm the pastor here
and it's this is a special night and
um it's a joy to get to introduce a dear
friend of mine uh Jesse Watts y'all give
him a hand
[Music]
there y'all go
um Jesse is
um so I met I met Jesse 2014. we went to
Seminary together
and uh that's that's how we met and then
we're there's like a whole back story we
start a different community and
um and he moved to help start it which
is such a selfless thing like he was um
had been a youth pastor for many years
and then he was a pastor of a church for
a number of years
um and like moved to help and
um it was you know a few years later we
ended up starting we wanted a more you
know inclusive affirming big table of
Christianity kind of place which is this
table and uh So eventually and then he
even followed us over here I mean just
so like um yesterday we not only go way
back but
um and I kind of just such a good friend
but he is I was thinking like you know
how do I what's like the heart of of
Jesse and he's not only a great I mean
you most of you know him as a musician
he's often playing guitar up here
um and not only is he like an artist and
a poet but there's this um little part
where the Apostle Paul talks about how
you have like a lot of like Christian
you know brothers and sisters among you
you don't necessarily have
um many uh spiritual like fathers and
mothers and uh when I think of Jesse in
his heart for the church
his heart for people
um it just he is like such a just a in a
in a really meaningful way he's like a
spiritual father and
um so I encourage you tonight to
um I don't know just be in that mode of
like you know receiving and don't worry
you're in good hands I know sometimes
when you know there's like the guests to
preach or whatever it's like oh no but
no no he's done this one bajillion times
um so he's it's gonna be fine
um he really is um just a great guy so
anyway all right Jesse all right it's
all yours friend all yours I'll give it
up for him
um how red is my face at the moment what
shade of red
um
yeah it it is really cool to get to
stand up here and share with this
community kind of like what Brett said
it there's just been so much history
that goes into this like I can remember
being in seminary late night
conversations about this and seeing it
like happen I know I talked about this
last time but it really is like it's it
is so beautiful to get to see this
become a reality
um it's it's so great
um so I hope you all had a marvelous
Easter last week did you have a good
Easter can everyone raise their hand who
was at our Easter Service it was so good
okay I am making a note of who wasn't
there
um because you will be cornered by a
group of people later Traders
um no in in all seriousness like we're
super glad to have you here whether you
are a newcomer an old-timer or an online
mom
um yeah do you like that it's all
downhill from here
um
uh no but it is it's really good to be
together I this time of the week I
really look forward to this because
there's certain people I just don't see
all week and it is such a blessing and
happy Easter tide
Easter tide
who's familiar with this word
that's what I thought good job so little
did you know last week we started a new
series uh about that coincides with the
the season of the church that's called
Easter tide and if you're not familiar
with that word which I think I saw two
hands who were familiar so
um it's very much like lent or Advent so
it's just it's just a season where we're
celebrating a certain thing so lent
we're we're celebrating we're not really
celebrating we're fasting and we're
confessing our need for a savior right
and then Advent is the days leading up
to Christmas where we're awaiting the
birth of Christ and so Easter tide is
the days following Easter we're in pure
celebration and joy mode you know
because of what Jesus came and he uh did
what
yes lived he rose from the dead and he
defeated I this is so tight I can't I
can't I'm gonna here we're gonna try
this
Bingo okay feel better did you feel me I
was feeling
ah okay
so yeah so Easter what Easter is though
is that it's this it's this celebration
of the life death and Resurrection
Resurrection specifically of Jesus right
and this is the climax of our faith the
climax of the story it is the happy
ending yes
yes this is how we treat Easter is that
it's like the happy ending to one of our
favorite movies and we watch it every
year and when it's done we're like oh
that was so good and then we turn it off
and we move on with our lives and we
don't think about it anymore
and we're like until next year when we
watch it again
right but here's this is why I love
Easter tide because Easter tide is a
reminder that the story is not over
it doesn't end to Easter Easter is not
the end it is really at that point the
story is just getting good it's just
getting good so that's what this series
is going to be all about and so tonight
we're going to see how the story
continues immediately after the
resurrection
um so we're going to be in the Gospel of
Luke in chapter 24 for those of you who
still use physical Bibles good for you
it will also be up here
um this story is famously called the
road to Emmaus familiar some of it the
road to Emmaus this is one of my very
very favorite stories ever since I was a
kid I'll talk about that a little bit
later
um but it is it is in the versus
immediately after the resurrection so
the context is that this is the exact
same day as the resurrection so the
verses right before Peter has gone to
the tomb and he has seen that Mary is
not a liar nor is she crazy and the tomb
indeed is empty and so you can imagine
like the the shock the confusion all of
that is still very fresh so we jump
right into this story
here we go are you ready
are we ready okay there you are all
right so now the same day two of them
were going to a village called Emmaus
about seven miles from Jerusalem they
were talking with each other about
everything that had happened as they
talked and discussed these things with
each other Jesus himself came up and
walked along with them but they were
kept from recognizing him he asked them
what are you discussing together as you
walk along so I I love this this is just
the very first part but these two people
they were they were asked and you gotta
imagine the amount of grief that they're
feeling like this is like a very sad
walk that they're not skipping they're
they are a sad walk back to Emmaus and
this guy comes up who is Jesus and they
they don't recognize them we'll talk
about that in a minute that's weird
um and they he's like what are you guys
talking about and they're like what what
do you mean what are we talking about
haven't you heard about all that's
happened in the last few days right and
he's like no I have it and you can
imagine they're like offended probably
super offended and so they're saying
that they begin to explain that what
happened to Jesus he was this man of God
a prophet Dynamic leader
um blessed by both God and the people
than than our high priests and leaders
they betrayed him and got him sentenced
to death so they clearly blame the
leaders which yes
um and and then they crucified him and
then there they say this this is
important we had our hopes up that he
was going to be the one to deliver
Israel we we've heard this right that
they thought Jesus was going to actually
physically overthrow the government
they're still thinking that at this
point
and so it's here we go
there there we are and so they had their
hopes up and that it is now the third
day they mentioned that it's the third
day he's really dead like it's over
except they're like we just heard that
our friends went and the tomb is empty
we are super confused and then Jesus
replies and we're not going to get into
it a lot right now but he replies he
basically shares the entire story of
scripture he says haven't you guys been
paying attention
that the whole story of scripture says
that this is going to happen this is the
bigger story
and so this story is so good and like I
said earlier
um when I was young I love this story my
grandparents actually had a painting of
this up on their wall and so I would
like look at this painting and I would
read this story over and over again I
loved how this portrayed Jesus I would
read the story and I would read this
little piece about Jesus because Jesus
seemed like a wizard
he seemed like a wizard to me and I I'm
not I'm not kidding I love this story
for one reason and one reason alone is
that because Jesus was doing tricks
he was doing tricks I mean the first one
and we pass over it pretty quickly is
that he walks up to these people and it
says they were kept from recognizing him
so he was like concealing his identity
with some sort of like spell you know
who knows it's so confusing and then
later later in the story
we will see that he actually ends up
disappearing from a room like they go
they take him to their house they have
dinner and they suddenly recognize him
and as they recognize him poof gone
like a wizard
like a wizard right I was so
wholeheartedly focused on these elements
of the story from a very like for a very
long time in my life and I probably like
it for the same reasons I love Harry
Potter
um do we have any Potter heads in the
room anyway yes okay so after this we're
gonna have a meeting we're gonna share
about which Hogwarts house we're in
um probably not but if you're wondering
Ravenclaw
um so so recently I actually read
through all the books um for the first
time I've watched the movies once a year
forever and um I love I love it I'm a
super fan but what I noticed is there's
this thing in the movies there's always
this one scene in one line that gets
repeated in every movie and something
magical and Fantastical will happen and
then Harry Potter will say I love Magic
every movie I think except for the last
one and I love that line because that's
how I feel reading the road to Emmaus is
this thing happens I feel like this kid
that I'm just like I love magic Jesus
disappearing cloak of invisibility
um
and
I know
I know I think if we're being honest
I think if we're being honest with
ourselves it's moments like these that
make the gospels fun to read
it I mean we're gonna be real here this
it's it's moments like these that make
the gospels fun to read I mean the
Turning water into wine who wouldn't
love that
um Healing The Sick raising people from
the dead multiplying the Loaves on the
fish from just a few things calming the
storm with his voice walking on water
all of these things
all of these stories are exciting and
interesting to read
you might as well rename the gospels The
Wizarding World of Jesus Christ
but there's a problem and really a
really significant one when you when you
think about how we approach the gospels
um and one is that these aren't just
stories to us right the the the the the
stories of Harry Potter and gospels we
do not hold them in the same category
right but then an even bigger problem is
that we have been conditioned to
gravitate and seek out what is most
entertaining
I mean I'm a special education teacher
and the for elementary students in
specifically first graders and the
amount of things that we have to do to
keep their attention it's just pure
entertainment like we have to turn
learning into entertainment to even keep
their attention for even a few minutes
it's it's remarkable it baffles me and
but even think about
um social media Instagram Tic Tac I mean
Tick Tock
um
and that was on purpose
um and and Facebook when you're
scrolling the algorithm is in a split
second learning what you like and what
will keep your attention and then it is
specifically curating things sending it
to you they like cat videos cat videos
cat videos
it's a little freaky
I mean just all of a sudden you have a
machine learning what keeps your
attention and they will only send you
what keeps your attention not the other
stuff and you all you think you're doing
is just scrolling but you're actually
being led down a path
so when we come to these stories in the
gospel we naturally focus on what is
most fantastical
it's just it's just how we've been
trained how we've been wired
and when we get too immersed in what
entertains us we miss the deeper truths
we miss what can be found in between and
beneath
um these these Miracles and events
focusing on the Fantastical makes us
miss the main points over and over and
over again
I wrote in here take a deep breath
so I want to get back to the story so
these two people who Scholars are kind
of they debate they don't really know
who they are
um these two people unknowingly walking
with Jesus there they shared this thing
with him of all that's happened to him
but they don't know that and he starts
going Story by story for starting with
Moses he goes Story by Story by story
connecting all the dots for them and
they get so excited by this conversation
that he's getting ready to walk on and
they're like no no stay for dinner
please let's stay for dinner we can keep
talking so they go in they sit down and
Jesus
I mean I don't know if I would let a
stranger touch my food right away but
they let him take the bread break it and
bless it and as he's handing it to them
suddenly they recognize him
and then he disappears
he just disappears and they are in shock
and awe they're like oh my gosh did we
not feel our hearts burning inside of us
when we were talking on the road with
him they're probably super confused of
like how did we not know that this was
him Magic
my mind always jumps to this
disappearing act that Jesus does and
thinks that that's why they were so
excited and thinking like oh he
disappeared that's why that's how they
knew that he was Jesus that's how they
recognized him because nobody can do
that
nobody is just disappearing randomly out
of the room after they break the bread
but actually as I read this a little bit
closer
it wasn't when Jesus disappeared that
they recognized him
they got excited that it was Jesus
it's when he broke the bread
he broke the bread he blessed it and he
handed it to them
it was when he blessed the meal it was
when he did the very human ordinary act
that anybody at that table could have
done
it was not
Supernatural it was not wizardly
it was a very ordinary thing that
anybody could have done
they recognized him at the dinner table
breaking bread because that's how they
knew him
they knew him as this person who broke
the bread and served it was at an
ordinary meal in an ordinary house when
an ordinary loaf was being divided that
these people recognized their savior
you see the road to Emmaus isn't a story
about Jesus proving that he's the son of
God by magic tricks and
disappearing and cloak of invisibility
it's so that he's not proving that he's
the son of God
no this is this is a story
about recognizing the presence of Jesus
in our everyday ordinary lives
not in the fantastical
I love this because it flies in the face
of the idea that Jesus came to prove
he was who he was he that he wasn't
there to prove anything Henry nowin says
it this way I love how he says this
Jesus refused to be a stunt man he did
not come to walk on hot coals swallow
fire or put his hand in a lion's mouth
to demonstrate that he had something
worthwhile to say
but we are so latched on to the magic
tricks
to the Miracles
and we know we know this to be true
because Paul writes this in Philippians
it's not going to be up there so just
listen we got this in your relationships
with one another have the same mindset
as Christ Jesus who being in very nature
God did not consider equality with God
something to be used to his own
Advantage rather he made himself nothing
or ordinary
by taking the very nature of a servant
being made in human likeness or ordinary
and being found in appearance as a man
ordinary he humbled himself by becoming
obedient to death even death on a cross
this does not sound like Jesus came to
impress or be spectacular
but that he came to be like us
to be very human and very ordinary
in a lot of ways
now I want to be very clear because I
can feel it I I can feel it I'm not
saying that Jesus wasn't extraordinary
no he because he was very much so
extraordinary mind-blowing
but so I'm not I'm not downplaying or
devaluing the Miracles or these things
at all please do not hear me say that
what I am saying is I want us to view
them properly so that we don't downplay
or devalue the other parts of the story
that are just as important does that
make sense so so what is
what is our task what is our practice to
be in light of this kind of shift from
uh focusing on the Fantastical and more
focusing on the ordinary and that is
just this that we must practice
recognizing the presence of Jesus in our
ordinary moments of Our Lives just the
ordinary everyday stuff but we are not
very good at that
we're not very good at that in fact if
you remember what we talked about
earlier it's actually very
counter-cultural to focus on the
ordinary
um our culture actually wants us to
reject the ordinary to distract
ourselves and strive for the
extraordinary so maybe we can get on a
TV show like it's I mean
and
and here's the thing even contemporary
Christian culture has encouraged this
um I experienced this first when I was a
Youngster probably
oh I was probably a late elementary
junior high and I was learning about
spiritual gifts
and for a short season I was around a
lot of charismatic Christians
um that were like over the top and and I
grew up Lutheran and Quaker
um which so the things that they were
doing felt strange and weird but also
kind of wonderful like it was very it
was very interesting and so I'm watching
these people like speak words of
Prophecy and like basically for me at
that time I was like they can tell the
future and then I'm seeing them like lay
hands on people and they're supposedly
healing people right then and there and
I'm seeing them speak this really weird
like foreign language that only God can
understand and that they're supposed to
be an interpreter but that's never
really happened
um
and I'm like just
I'm amazed and I'm just like this is so
cool and I'm looking at people
um speaking in tongues and I'm like I
want to do that that's cool so also
side note
um there might be some of you thinking
right now as I'm bringing up spiritual
gifts finally we're going to talk about
spiritual gifts I've been waiting and
then there might be some of you who feel
super triggered right now and are like I
need to leave
both things are okay both things are
okay I'm just sharing my experience with
specifically speaking in tongues
and so when I noticed that I wanted this
I went up to people who would do this I
say how do I do that
and they're like look it's it's the
spiritual gift of speaking in tongues it
is a Heavenly language intimacy uh
leveling up in your connection with God
and all you have to do is ask I might
ask who who they're like God ask God I'm
like great this is awesome so I go home
and I immediately start praying
Lord
I want to speak this cool powerful
magical language that everyone else get
is speaking and it just looks and sounds
so cool and I kept praying and praying
and praying and then I would like try it
I'd be like
nothing would happen
and so I'd pray and pray and pray
nothing nothing is happening
and so my my prayers kind of turn from
asking to begging
because I'm starting to question whether
God wants that connection with me
like why are all these other people
get this and we're given this by God and
I'm not being given this by God
and so I'm like begging God like please
like
I love you like I will do anything to
have this deeper connection with you to
speak this cool language like I'll do
anything and I remember even at times
just weeping in my room confused as to
why this wasn't happening for me I'm
like why don't I get the magic
it never happened for me
I gave up I gave up that prayer and I
remember just being super discouraged
because then some people are saying ah
you may not be saved
which that's a whole nother
I'll let Brett handle that one
but the thing was as I as I thought
about it I thought about it this way
that I was so consumed with asking for
this deeper Connection in this other
language I never spent any time in my
own language connecting with God
I was so consumed with trying to speak
to God in this cool foreign language
that I never listened
I never took time in silence I never
used my own language that I was pretty
good at
since I learned how to speak I never
used my language to connect with God on
a deeper level
you see this is why I I believe we must
shift our attention from striving to see
God in the extraordinary to Experiencing
God in the everyday ordinary moments of
Our Lives because like my own language
didn't feel good enough
it didn't feel cool enough or
extraordinary enough
it felt too ordinary too mundane not
special
and here's the thing like the miraculous
is very real to me
very real I'm not saying that those
things are not real
but here's what I am saying the
miraculous
those things are kind of few and far
between
in our ordinary moments are kind of all
the time
and I want to see Jesus in my ordinary
moments because that means more
more often
more more experience of Jesus presence
so so how do we do this how do we begin
to recognize the presence of Christ in
the ordinary moments of Our Lives well
there are 1 000 things we could do to do
this like and I mean I could name really
I could do like seven more sermons just
on the spiritual disciplines and
practices that would help
make this happen
but we're going to talk about one just
one just one thing and that is this
we need to slow down
um I really wanted to add some other
words in between slow and not slow the
down because
I'll be the first to admit I'm horrible
at this I'm horrible at this I mean I
especially lately I'm in my first year
of teaching and it's testing season and
I'm working on my certification and I've
often described My Life as a runaway
train that just seems to be getting
faster and faster and faster and and so
when I say I'm busy I really am busy I
know some people who say they're busy
just to get out of things and they're
not really busy I am not one of those
people I am really truly busy and and
but busyness it's cool I've noticed this
busyness is celebrated in our culture
celebrated encouraged I I've seen so
many posts on like on Instagram I saw
one where a guy was working through his
lunch and he was like oh working through
my lunch hashtag no days off
like like like like like like then I saw
one the other day on Facebook where
somebody posted a picture of their clock
have you seen people do this 3 A.M he's
like well you're sleeping I'm starting
my second business hashtag no days off
those things are not bad
they're not bad but you know what I
don't see
like hey I just sat in silence for 30
minutes I'm really feeling relaxed
hashtag rest hashtag slow down
I don't see that as often
because it's not celebrated
it's not celebrating I'm not talking
vacation posts that's different that's
still busy
like actually slowing down
but it and it's not encouraged but it
slowing down is absolutely necessary if
we're going to have any chance at
becoming more aware of the presence of
Jesus in our ordinary lives like it has
to happen
and and really it's really it's us
practicing being present like we want to
recognize the presence of Jesus in our
ordinary moments we cannot do that if we
ourselves are not present
we can't we cannot expect to see that if
we ourselves are not present
so one of my favorite one of my favorite
Quaker writers Richard Foster he said
this back in the 70s listen to this
superficiality is the curse of our age
the desperate need today is not for a
greater number of intelligent people or
gifted people but for deep people
I know you're thinking what is that
doesn't seem like it connects it doesn't
really
um but his son Nathan Foster took that
quote and he rewrote it for our current
cultural moment he said it this way
distraction
is the curse of our age the desperate
need today is not for a greater number
of efficient or busy people but for
present people
that word efficient
I I feel like every day I'm like God I
gotta be more efficient more efficient
more efficient I got to find a way to be
more efficient
to become people who recognize Jesus in
the ordinary we must transform from
people who are distracted to people who
are present
and and that's I mean here we are in
closing I literally have no homework for
you you know how some preachers will be
like do this and this and this and this
and your life will be better
I have no answers for you
um no homework for you to do but I do
want to Simply encourage you
Jesus is present with you in your daily
lives
he is
don't miss the sacred in the simple
the Divine in the ordinary the presence
of God in the mediocre and the mundane
you may find Jesus with you in the car
line when you're picking up your kids at
school you may feel your heart burning
as you do the dishes or walk your dog
you may even find yourself face to face
with Jesus when you're sharing a meal at
the table with good friends
slow down
open your eyes open your heart Jesus is
with you even here even now
so now as we come to our table
let us recognize Jesus in the breaking
of bread just as these people did
not in some crazy Fantastical magic
trick that we find Worthy
but in the simple breaking of bread with
our family
so this is the table
not of the church
but of the Lord
and it is made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow and you who
have failed come because it is the Lord
who invites you
it is his will that those who want him
should meet him here
come to the table
[Music]
foreign
take your time taking the elements and
when you're ready you can join in with
us
a song about exactly what we're doing
here
foreign
[Music]
have no rulers can be seated
from all Sinners
and come to the table
come here and far
come from the Shadows
[Music]
come to the banquet
come join in the field feel free to
stand and join us
[Music]
every
[Applause]
[Music]
Jesus
to a table full of grace to the table
come and
stay
and come to the table
Circle
[Music]
come down
I can't let down your guard
another
stranger
just come as you are
[Music]
me home
come be loved
come
accepted
come now come
[Music]
on
come now come
come be home
It's Gonna Be
Loved it's coming
come now come
head is the table
[Music]
we're ready to Feast
the party is waiting
is more still defeat
the hardest is ready
go fill everything
[Music]
go live out the mission
as a kingdom of praise
beautiful
[Music]
foreign
come down
[Music]
I think your worship team appreciate
that and thank you also just
for speaking tonight great reminders
if you're visiting with us today if as
you're exiting this door there is some a
small table and some cards if you
wouldn't mind just kind of filling out
just saying you know that you were here
we just like to have a record and just
say thank you for just being here we
appreciate that
um also if you um with that same there's
a little box if you want to you know
support this financially you can do that
there you can also go online and be able
to do that there as well
and before you guys leave we want to
send you out with this benediction
so you are a child of God
you are a child of God
and this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
this yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved that you're worthy and you are
accepted Just As You Are
and go filled with God's holy spirits
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact with
thank you have a good evening
[Music]
foreign
um accepted
[Music]
come now
come now come